hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the video where I finally
unbox your gifts from indie pop con and
I know this is months and months late
because indie pop con was actually on my
birthday June 28th and it's now whatever
day it may be I don't know I haven't
looked at the calendar yet okay but it's
finally time to unbox these gifts and
I've been meaning to do this for so long
but with the move and going to packs and
all the other things in July that I had
I had like 10 different things I was
going to I'm finally able to sit down
and go through these and show you guys
the cool stuff that people gave me any
pop con and I just got back from pax and
I love love going to these things
because I get to hang out with my
friends again that I don't get to see
enough you know I was hanging with Bob
Wade Jack and also cinnamon toast can
and pewdiepie and a whole bunch of other
youtubers that I can't list all of but I
love going to these things because I
come back so inspired to do more because
I like being around like-minded people I
like being around creative people I like
being around people that inspire me to
push myself to try new things and do
more things make better gaming videos
into sketch comedy and music videos and
you know I don't get that enough because
you know I used to be very isolated here
in LA you know I'm an introvert so I
live alone but now I live with the
cyndago guys and my new editor Matt
we're all in a big house together and
it's a great experience because now we
get to make the cool stuff that we want
to make all the time we have no excuse
we're all accountable for each other so
that's why I'm very excited because it's
going to be more sketches more music
videos more challenges that we're gonna
be doing a whole bunch of creative stuff
out of the blue totally weird and wonky
and it's gonna be awesome if some people
don't like it well that's just too bad
because we're having fun aren't we
anyway I'll expand more on this after I
get through the unboxing but one more
thing that I want to say before hand is
that this Friday we are doing a charity
livestream we're doing it for the
depression and bipolar Alliance and we
did this charity before but I wanted to
do it again because I kind of wanted to
reinvigorate I do want to do like the
nationwide group volunteering thing that
I promise that we'd be doing and I
actually do
have that in the works there's a company
that I work with or that I'm going to be
working with out in Arizona that does
exactly the same they organize large
volunteering events so we're gonna get
that underway but first this Friday
we're gonna be doing a charity
livestream and I did and I did order 20
more of the markiplier heroes engraved
eye pots to giveaway on the stream so if
you want to come by you don't need to
donate to be eligible to win we'll just
be doing a giveaway on whoever is in the
stream but this particular stream is
going to be on YouTube so you don't
actually have to go anywhere you don't
have to go over to twitch you don't have
to go anywhere else so just be here on
the stream on Friday and we'll do the
giveaway will donate money to the great
cause and then we'll just have a lot of
fun together and also another thing that
brought this up was when I was at PAX
you know I was talking to Bob Wade and
jack'd when I was hanging out with him I
was talking to him about how the size of
the channel is often discouraging for me
nothing that I'm you know ashamed to
have such a large following I'm honored
and in fact that's actually part of why
I was a bit discouraged because me I'm a
very isolated person you know I I can't
even fathom the idea of seeing 9 million
people in one place it's almost
impossible that's like more than the
population of most cities in the world
and the fact that that many people are
subscribed to me is daunting and so I
was getting discouraged by that not to
the point where I was singing it given
up but I was just talking to Jack and
Bob and weighed about and they're you
know I was addressing my concerns and
they just like dude what's wrong with
you get it together man you set up fool
so it was really weird because it was
just like it shook me it was like what
am i doing like why am I getting down on
this this is the greatest opportunity
that we could possibly have we have so
many people I just need to get to the
forefront of it and lead to so that this
community can actually be united towards
doing something good and I have been in
terms of the charity things but I need
to take less of a passive role in it and
be more engaged with you guys and that's
why after this video and starting next
week on Monday I'm gonna be starting a
reading your comment series where you
guys will give me questions and I'll
read and respond to them and funny in
serious ways because uh that's another
thing I was talking to Jack about
I wanted to do that for a while but I
you know I felt like it wasn't like
unique or anything but you just told me
that it's a great way to get involved in
the community and engage with you guys
which I don't have enough outlets to do
so there's a lot of cool things that I
want to be doing and there's a lot of
cool things that I want to make and
there's a lot of cool things that we are
going to make in the very near future so
I'm very excited about it I'll expand
more on that later I know it's been like
five minutes already but I'll get to
that second I got to get to this
unboxing it's gonna take me a long time
to go through all this I'll try to get
through this quickly as possible while
still giving people there.just alright
not to kill myself with the knife but
obviously there's gonna be a lot of
lettuce
oh oh so tiny oh it's a little tiny itty
bitty clay figure me looks like I got
some brown stuff on Mike but maybe I'm
supposed to be attached to something
wrong I have no idea about that but look
how cute he is
it's um this is like a metal this is
like a solid aluminum block that's
supposed to be tiny box Tim there's no
painted face on them but it's just like
Oh tiny box Tim you put on a little
weight there alright and then oh that
was really funny because I forgot that
when I was playing five nights at freak
boys I requested a pillow that says
inhale my dong actually I have another
pillow
but I have another pillow over here that
says inhale my dog can people still see
me I hope so
gosh George well yeah so I got a bunch
of pillows that say hey oh my dong on
them so that's it that's a thing that I
have decorating my house now bunch up
dong inhaling oh there's also this flip
book that is 20 reasons why we heart
markiplier I don't know if there's that
many reasons in general it's just funny
you can make us laugh even on our worst
days I'm funny like 20% of the time tiny
box Tim you made the little guy we all
know and love
three good looks or entertaining again
very questionable five awesome friends
definitely not questionable six drunk
minecraft which is coming back at might
star jack is a special guest seven
amazing voice which
that's good eight catchphrases oh man
searches simular doesn't but known a
while nine you're the king it doesn't
matter if it's the king of squirrels or
five nights at freddy's we love our king
anyway meeting 10 fans Oh Tammy meeting
fans it's something that might not seem
important but to us it is weird we are
able to meet the guy who can make our
day brighter that's okay
like they said sorry about messing it up
oh man this is so much stuff I'm barely
through the first boxing's already been
like five minutes that's crazy yeah but
just thank you guys so much
eleven fame didn't change who you are
yep I'm sitting here in my pajamas we're
going to video inform camera ain't the
fact that it's considered Fame wow
that's old that's a whole nother story I
can meet with you about twelve thankful
you're always thinking fans for helping
you get to where you are and it just
makes us happy that you feel that way
thirteen charity which we're gonna be
doing another one this Friday if you
remember my rambling from earlier
fourteen you inspire people fifteen you
help people sixteen dedication seventeen
you bring people together eighteen
started from nothing nineteen you help
us believe in ourselves and twenty you
tell us that we were important and you
are because most of these things right
here could actually be attributed to you
guys I mean maybe the funny and good
looks one I'll take for myself the
majority of these are because of you
guys and what this community has done
together and that's why I'm so proud of
what you guys have done that's really
cool it's so unfortunate because I can't
read everything that's in here and I
know there's a lot more stuff to be read
but I will get to that soon
oh you live bear with the pig mother joy
was that so no it was that oh is that me
like that oh it is love the stache holy
crap that's adorable
oh yeah I remember this it's a little
tiny box Tim that opens up and it has a
little note in it I can't read it right
now on camera oh it says mark on the
inside and there's a little mustache on
the other side oh man there's so much
cool stuff here's another little tiny
box Tim made out of clay
I've got like a hundred different tiny
box attempts throughout my house I mean
in the movie mustache games oh these are
probably old I probably should need them
here I go
yep they're old - got a dollar
I got a dollar and I got a little
markiplier beanie good my hair is not on
point this morning there we go do I look
good everybody no okay all right
can you still see me am I still am I on
frame now I have no idea I don't know
I'm asking because I'm looking so long
and we got a bunch of letters here like
I really wish I could read through all
of these and it seems like it seemed
mean that you know when I say that I
can't read through all these but I
literally don't have the time because if
I dedicated to reading all of these it
was like in my old mail opening videos
there were so many letters and stuff
there and that's why I don't have a peel
box anymore because like I I'm honored
to receive these gifts that I'm honored
to get these in and sometimes that
conventions I'm even hesitant to accept
gifts because I'm just like there's so
much stuff here I can't give everything
the love and attention that it deserves
give this love to each other give this
love to each other I don't deserve all
of this stuff we got a gift bag see what
I meant when I said I get lots of time I
said there's another adorable little
tiny box Tim tiny box in by the way tiny
box Tim plushies are coming I know I say
that all the time but they definitely
are coming in soon there's and those 90
likes Tim and wait I think there's
another one of her oh no there's there's
a the other and actually well made tiny
box Tim plushies with little dangly arms
oh I can't do the voice
try to sleep - yeah come on cam
here's another inhale my dong pillow
like I said I'm gonna have the whole
house decorated every couch when people
come over they're going to be extremely
confused who extremely arose not like
that I didn't know what to expect when I
first found you but I'm happy I did you
gave me my confidence back and you made
each day of my life so much brighter I
became so drawn to your silly
personality and your characters you
truly amazed me by being the unique man
you still are today the day I found it
was the same day I found tiny boxes Tim
- I may not have known you since the
very beginning but I would happily
follow you and support you until the
very end I know there's more into this
book but just thank you so much who is
this from Molly meep
thank you very much Molly oh it's a
little [ __ ] I can't quite make out
what is in the inscription because it
looks oh no I was looking at the wrong
side I'm a freaking idiot that's what
I'm doing it's an end it's the
markiplier em like with a little tiny
itty bitty mustache on it oh that's
adorable yeah there what else we got we
got move a disc shot without a batteries
or something does it even run on
batteries don't even know what I'm
[Music]
well I'm so happy that that happened oh
oh there we go
yeah I have to pick those up later dang
it
a big pink mustache from Alyssa thank
you very much there's a message on the
back door ah there's a shirt here for
Canadian Texas bull shirt I don't know
what that means let's see oh we got a
little Deadpool plushie oh it better not
be crap or else this guy's gonna come
and murder you take news we got a little
bumpers no breathe
oh I think I remember this this is a jar
of messages from many people either on
tumblr or Twitter or there's a jar
messages from you guys so I will get to
this one I will try to read that one
right over there so that I don't miss it
okay it looks like we got a gift here
and once again if I don't if I happen to
overlook your gift please don't be upset
because I there's literally so much
stuff here that I obviously can't get to
everything so oh cool looks like I got a
book here that is some you take some
loose daven glasses or something
somebody trying to say hmm we got some
sort of a birthday present here oh I
thought it was an arrow to headbands
some people might think it is but in all
honesty it's just an epic headband which
is exactly the thing that I am cool yet
okay and last thing in here that I'm
going to open it is a giant tiny back
ship so that makes one two three four
five six seven eight nine tiny bugs Tim
so far this is a lot but there's
something and you do let me just open
your face oh oh I think Jack got
something similar to this it's it's so
smells nice so I'm assuming it's soap so
I'm pretty sure that's soap
if not it's a very strange blue oh man
I'm already I'm just moving this pile to
another less organized pile right here
so hmm
okay I don't know what this is it looks
like a blanket I think it's a blanket
I'm pretty sure this is a blanket with a
note on it sorry I couldn't meet you I
made this blanket for your birthday
happy birthday Mark Grace Swan thank you
so much I guess I guess you couldn't
make it through the line oh cool the
Bioshock shirt oh we had a tiny box Tim
inside of another exciting back stem I
guess technically there's like my
birthday on the boxes or something like
that it's empty
it was empty empty
oh okay bye as like a framed painting
with some letters in it thank you so
much may see a ruder thank you very much
oh wow that's cool oh man it's a little
dude oh man I loved inside out inside
that was such a good movie I cried like
three times
oh it's pure Oh it loves Spira well this
looks a handmade
I love spear so much Spiros like an
amazing game I didn't I played it on the
channel and I was just kinda like game
and then I couldn't stop saying that but
it is a really really good game I highly
recommend it to everyone it's free game
on the grounds really fun really cool
great game mechanics awesome game oh oh
yeah the inflatable
kink wrapping up won't say let me blow
into this okay there we go I'm the king
of something woah oh holy crap woah nice
big don't take this audio out of context
whoo-hoo-hoo don't put this in a septa
player fan thing why do I have one of
John Lasseter's shirts why did someone
give me socks because for every birthday
I guess at one point or another you get
socks I do like socks those socks are
nice thank you boxers
I prefer boxer briefs to be honest but
thank you wait thinks I'm a waist 38 Oh
insulting a little dog I'm gonna get a
dog I am going to get a dog and I'm
gonna be like a dog daddy is what I'm
gonna be that sounds weird
okay oh that's right Rico is Roughnecks
when I was at one of those down there
one of my favorite movies of all time of
Starship Troopers and when we were down
there we actually got to meet and kind
of hang out with Casper Van Dien who was
Rico Johnny Rico in Starship Troopers
who's really weird like he's such a cool
guy - like we were me Jax Bob wait we're
all standing early oh they're so cool
like oh this is Johnny Rico over here
now is Johnny Cage and it's like really
cool so anyway it's a unicorn whoa okay
alright we got we got some big stuff
here what is that
pillow oh it's a pillow oh it's a big
pillow and on the back it does say
inhale my dong on it this is a really
nice pillow Oh answers Anthony thank you
so much Anthony for that I'm gonna put
it under my butt right now
you're welcome you're welcome okay I
think we got a bunch of paintings in
this one yeah I think this is the
painting box I'll try not to uh whoa oh
I remember I have to unwrap this one
okay I don't know if you guys can see
this one quite well but it's my face
made up of other characters in five
nights at freddys there's a really
creepy one the puppet here that's my
mouth like I don't know why the puppet
has a stache and teeth and a tongue but
that's so weird and so disturbing but in
the best way because it's supposed to be
disturbing like it's five nights at
Freddy's this is really really cool and
I didn't see a name on it but you know
who you are thank you so much for making
this one
ah that's er oh that's right it was a
mirror it's a mirror like that I could
look into and remind it cuz it says you
are our hero mark from Adrian Allen's
you get a sneak peek of everything
that's behind the scenes a camera man no
it's so well done this so well done oh
thank you so much I don't see a name on
this one but thank you so much for
making this one this is awesome
yeah we got one that's I think me is
just just my face and a portrait either
I'm talking about sailors as me from
Eric green thank you very much doll we
got a little bit get over here you know
you can enjoy we'll build 50 I think it
says all the stars and no more Kirsten
be for making this one thank you very
much it might be from to the moon I'm
not entirely sure letters and numbers
because I need to learn my alphabet and
my countable z-- oh we're making through
I think we're about halfway through yeah
I think we're about halfway through whoa
okay this box might be a little bit
easier because we got a not so tiny tiny
box Tim
oh no no no no no no it's Oh No
oh no it was like a mustache sticker
magnet something oh no a little bit of
bloodshot eye going on here I'm gonna
try to carefully remove this but thank
you so much for that oh whoa oh it's
like a it's a cross stitch of I don't
know if that's the actual name of but
it's cross this of the moment from the
tiny mite STEMI innovation that's we got
a tiny box ten pillow oh oh no it's so
horrible don't look children oh god no
another beanie good enough what's in the
bus smell here why is the pox a smell
here but it smells like a thing I'm not
sure what it smells like but it smells
it's a smelly smell it smells smelly Oh
oh it was a candleholder oh okay that
makes more sense okay so this was a
candle holder before this candle which
I'm assuming is what was the smelly
smell that was smelling smelling really
well done drawing of me on the front of
the little note oh okay let's go kids
okay mark words cannot describe how
amazing of a person you are and how much
you inspire me
being ill with chronic pain since I was
12
depression was a common issue for me but
the day I found you and watched you on
long days laying in bed waiting for pain
to pass make them bearable you and your
own story not just inspire me
artistically but mentally and physically
as well thank you love Whitney well I
hope you're doing much better now I hope
things are going much better for you in
the future thank you so much for this
box I'm assuming this doctor that
because of the tie looks a little crude
EB but I think it still lock today it's
actually cute reminds me a little baby
for men in black the horrible horrible
baby
[Music]
it might be Megan I think that might be
Mary your fan Megan I believe that's
Megan which is like this stuff like this
it's so cool because people took time to
make this like I may think that it takes
a while to unbox all but this alone
probably took someone like an hour to
make or more like it's really cool and I
have to be grateful but at the same time
I'm like do I deserve me know we get a
little day oh yeah some big here yeah
eat em eat em down with them what - I'm
gonna put that up on my wall it's got
little mounting points on the back of it
- so this is definitely something that's
meant to be put on a little tear mark
this pillow is not only a gift for your
birthday but also a reminder for you lay
your head down at night
we hope it reminds you that you've
helped so many people and made us so
happy we know that you're happy knowing
you've helped so many and inspired so
many and we hope looking at this pillow
reminds me you of all you've done for us
and all the happiness it brings us and
that you go to sleep with a smile on
your face every night because we'd love
to see you happy
mark we love to see you happy one so it
kind of works like a dream catcher
except that bad stuff is gone before you
sleep happy birthday mark Sarah and
Maddie thank you very much
oh that's so cool I wonder what it could
be all wake up Mike it almost looks like
a bloody markiplier em there I believe
in something small I sure do
tiny bugs damn is awesome thank you so
much for this Oh super birthday girls I
don't know that that's me but I can't
exactly argue with something as sparkly
as this I'm a super birthday girl
where's my bling kind of a silhouette
style me by Lorde mash Oh Mikaela pepper
another painting of my logo we have a
tiny box salmon a marklar and mark you
are an amazing person love your vids you
never fail to make my day thank you for
being awesome loved Becky Cooper thank
you very much
boy it'd be bad if I went through this
whole video and I discovered the camera
wasn't even on me the whole time
whoa it's kitty but someone sticks them
into the top of it oh poor kid about to
hurt a little bit but he looks pretty
happy this is how you pet kitties
Jessica okay okay Wow got another part
of our beanie gate here we go
you got another crown my head is
gigantic by the way so not a lot of
things oh wow that's cool yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh did I break it
no I didn't break it oh there's no name
on this one oh thank you very much oh
yeah someone made a markiplier dolls
here that actually this is really cool
because it's Marta wire for and friends
and it starts with just the red
container and then I believe this is
Wade and then inside wave there's gin
Santa Cooley and inside Juke safety
Cooley there's me
oh I'm tiny I'm in DBT do we do be DBT
this is actually really cool I like this
a lot and then inside I bet there's Bob
I don't see a name on it but someone
made me as an attack on Titan character
probably one of the ones that dies like
right away because I'm not very skilled
at what I do and I'm uncoordinated or
maybe by sheer luck I just so happened
to stumble through everything and
managed to kill me a Titan and then died
horribly horribly horribly horribly in a
nail my dong enragement pillow ha inhale
my dong I wonder if there's gonna be a
five minutes of freak boys or looks like
we got another pillow here man way too
many pillows it's a mustache pillow
thank you very much there go yeah okay
then we got a framed
CrossFit's crochet thing of inhale my
dong enragement child oh wow so
shut up nurse t-shirt and a v-neck - Oh
like the little box I start it's a jar
of stars from Sarah Gregor thank you
very much Sarah
Oh tiny like yeah that's Dora oh wait a
minute whoa I think I might have gotten
something of Jax
I've got Jack's pillow Jack if you want
your pillow case back you'll never come
to babe better come to LA if you want to
come get it please loss at all okay we
got another tiny box - oh this looks
like did someone give me - uh it's a
little wire ring that someone made I
guess someone wanted to ask me an
important question the answer is no big
uns okay
there's a lot of lows here I wish I
could read them all right now but I
definitely can't so thank you everybody
who wrote a letter I really do
appreciate it I really wish I just had
more time in my life and someone gave me
a selfie stick last one last one
we got a t-shirt of some sort that says
oh you can guess what it says it says
inhale my dog it's really creepy eyes I
would scare some people we've got a
silhouette painting from Paulette rep on
the air thank you very much this one's
actually really well done we've got oh
boy oh oh oh no oh yeah I forgot about
this one that's right oh it's it's it's
a three part poster okay it's a three
part painting with a light-up back so it
gets mounted up and then you can flip
the switch and then light it on so I
accidentally ripped one of the things
loose from the other ones but I can fix
that so thank you very much there's no
name on it right now but thank you thank
you thank you I'll try not to
yeah
[ __ ] and all a letter I really outlook
it's a DVD of circuit few words we sure
know that oh yeah this uh this is the
president this is this is quiet blue
this is supposed to go on walls to make
things quieter the front away scream
really really loudly anyway so I guess
that is everything here thank you guys
so much for all these gifts I am sitting
literally in an ocean of love from you
guys so thank you from the bottom of my
heart really really thank you for all
this I wish that I could go through
everything personally I know there's
things that I missed or didn't give
enough attention to but there's just so
much stuff here so just from me to you
thank you all so much for making this
stuff more you for giving this stuff for
taking the time to come meet us even
though we were rushed and it's things
like that but just thank you for all the
birthday wishes and thank you so much
for being here with me for so long and
going into the future I'm really really
excited because there's going to be so
many cool things coming out of the next
few weeks and starting the reading your
comment series and I've got so many new
ideas for things that we got at so many
sketch ideas on learning music I'm
learning languages I was trying so many
different things and I just wanted to
say you know thank you for being here
with me for so long I really am like
sorry that I've taken like a passive
role and a lot of things I haven't been
very engaging on a lot of social media
I haven't been engaging in the comments
but that's gonna change real soon
so thank you everybody again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye